All across the country this month college freshmen are starting their new lives at their new schools. And it is so hard to get into so many schools these days. At Columbia University in New York City, 33,000 people applied. 31,000 were rejected. That is fewer than 7% getting in.
本月，全国各地的大学新生都在校园里开启了新生活。如今，考上大学非常困难。在纽约市的哥伦比亚大学，有33,000人申请，其中31,000人被拒。录取率不到7%。
And the students who did get in, the students who made it here, they still wonder how they did it. You know, it was so hard to get here, what was it that worked? And they have their theories.
而那些被录取、成功进入校园的学生，至今仍在纳闷自己是怎么做到的。你知道，考进来太难了，到底是哪里奏效了呢？他们都有自己的理论。
I think it's because my application was very focused on physics, and especially females in physics, because obviously that's a problem.
我觉得是因为我的申请非常专注于物理学，尤其是女性在物理学领域的参与，因为这显然是个问题。
I had decent SAT scores, and I had a good GPA, but I think a big part of it was my essays.
我的SAT成绩不错，GPA也很好，但我认为很大一部分原因在于我的申请文书。
These Columbia students talked to reporter Phia Bennin. On their very first day on campus, it was obvious who is a freshman because they all had to wear neon bracelets, like they were at a waterpark.
这些哥伦比亚大学的学生接受了记者菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）的采访。在他们入校的第一天，谁是新生一眼就能看出来，因为他们都戴着霓虹灯手环，就像在水上乐园一样。
Well, I've been a competitive gymnast for my entire life.
嗯，我这辈子一直是一名竞技体操运动员。
I was a rhythmic gymnast, and I competed for the US national team.
我是练艺术体操的，曾代表美国国家队参赛。
I don't know. I'm pretty diverse, I guess-- Hispanic, disabled, good grades.
我不知道。我觉得我挺多元的——西班牙裔、残疾人，成绩也不错。
I'm an Eagle Scout. That might have helped too.
我是鹰级童子军。这可能也有帮助。
But you do not have to talk to many kids or scratch the surface very far at all before you get this response to the question, what got you into this school?
但你不需要问太多孩子，或者稍微深入了解一下，就能听到他们对“你为什么会被这所学校录取？”这个问题作出的回应。
I have no idea.
我不知道。
I still actually have no clue whatsoever.
我其实至今仍毫无头绪。
Just the percentage of people that get in is just absolutely minuscule, so it's just what the admissions officers see in you. And I have no idea what they saw. [CHUCKLING]
录取率简直低得离谱，所以这完全取决于招生官在你身上看到了什么。而我根本不知道他们看到了什么。[笑声]
You have no idea what?
你说你不知道什么？
No.
没有。
I totally relate to that. I remember I was completely clueless when it came to applying to college-- what to do to get in, what to say on the essays to convince them that I was worthy of their schools. And even more basic than that, I really had no idea what would possibly make one school better than another, how to figure out what schools I should apply to. It was overwhelming.
我完全能体会。我记得申请大学时我完全是两眼一抹黑——不知道该做什么才能被录取，不知道文书里该写些什么才能说服他们我是值得被录取的。更基本的是，我真的不知道哪所学校可能比另一所好，也不知道该怎么确定自己应该申请哪些学校。这太让人不知所措了。
And today on our show-- it's September, it's back to school-- we have stories of some of the most boneheaded things people try to do to get into college, plus the truly incredible story of how one man made it into college. That story from writer, Michael Lewis. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中——现在是九月，又是开学季——我们准备了一些关于人们为了上大学而做的最蠢事的故事，还有一位男士如何考上大学的真实且不可思议的故事。那个故事来自作家迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one, "The Old College Try." So here at our radio show, we went looking for a college admissions officer who would tell us the most misguided things that people do when they're applying to schools. And we found Rick Clark, who's director of undergraduate admissions at the Georgia Institute of Technology, better known as Georgia Tech. And he said that he and his team are regularly getting emails and phone calls from parents who are pretending to be their own kids. And he sent me some of these emails with the names redacted.
第一幕，“老派大学尝试”。我们电台去寻找了一位愿意讲述人们在申请学校时所做的最离谱事情的招生官。我们找到了佐治亚理工学院（简称佐治亚理工）的本科招生主任里克·克拉克（Rick Clark）。他说，他和他的团队经常收到家长假冒孩子发来的邮件和打来的电话。他给我转发了一些名字已遮盖的邮件。
You forwarded an email like this to us. This is from a mom's email address, and then it's signed from a son.
你转发了一封这样的邮件给我们。这是从一位妈妈的邮箱发出的，但落款是儿子的名字。
Yeah, yeah.
对，没错。
And it says, "I was impressed by GT's beautiful campus and its close proximity to so many athletic teams and facilities in Atlanta. I look forward to speaking with someone from the business school. Thanks again for taking the time to meet with us on Saturday, and thanks for the awesome T-shirt." Now, the word awesome, is that the most common word that parents use to imitate their kids?
上面写着：“我对GT美丽的校园以及它在亚特兰大与众多运动队和设施的近距离感到印象深刻。我期待着与商学院的某位人士交谈。再次感谢您周六抽出时间与我们会面，也感谢那件超赞的T恤。”现在，“超赞”（awesome）这个词，是家长模仿孩子说话时最常用的词吗？
I'd say "awesome" and "cool." If they throw those in, I think they feel like they're covering their bases on impersonating a high school student. But ironically, I really almost never, in fact, see that in an email from a high school student.
我会说“超赞”和“酷”。如果他们用了这些词，我觉得他们认为自己在模仿高中生方面已经做得天衣无缝了。但讽刺的是，我几乎从不在高中生的邮件里看到这些词。
Ah. So Duplicitous parents, please take note. And then on the phone, when the parents call on the phone, do they use the word "awesome?"
啊。所以，虚伪的家长们请注意了。那么在电话里，当家长打电话时，他们会用“超赞”这个词吗？
I actually just did hear from one of my staff members who said they talked to a mom the other day who clearly was trying to sound like her 17-year-old daughter, not so much in the language she was using, but masking her voice. About 15 minutes in, she started using "she" instead of "I," even saying, what if she-- I mean, I wanted to list more activities on the application?
我的一位同事刚跟我说，他们前几天接到一位妈妈的电话，她显然在试图模仿她17岁的女儿，不是通过用词，而是伪装声音。大约过了15分钟，她开始用“她”而不是“我”，甚至说，要是她——我是说，我想在申请材料里多列出一些活动，该怎么办？
Rick Clark says that one thing that has amped this up, all the parents getting in touch, is that lots of schools take into account whether a student shows something called demonstrated interest in their college, meaning, did they show up on campus? Did they write emails to the admissions office afterwards? Were they in touch?
里克·克拉克说，让这种事情愈演愈烈、让家长们纷纷介入的一件事是，很多学校会考虑学生是否展示了所谓的“表现出的兴趣”（demonstrated interest），意思是，他们是否来过校园参观？事后是否给招生办写过邮件？是否保持过联系？
Georgia Tech, he says, does not take that stuff into account, but parents do not seem to have gotten the memo on that. He forwarded me an email that a mom wrote to her kid, offering the kid $20 if the kid would email the admissions office, which might have been fine if she hadn't accidentally sent her email to the admissions office. And Rick Clark says that he gets where the parents are coming from. He is a parent himself. He wants to do everything he can for his kids.
他说，佐治亚理工不会考虑这些，但家长们似乎并没有收到这个消息。他转发给我一封妈妈写给孩子的邮件，承诺如果孩子给招生办发邮件就给孩子20美元，如果她不是不小心把这封邮件发给招生办的话，这可能没什么问题。里克·克拉克说，他理解家长的出发点。他自己也是个父亲，他想为孩子做任何他能做的事。
In fact, we've got a five-year-old right now on a waiting list for a charter school.
事实上，我们现在有个五岁的孩子正在一所特许学校的候补名单上。
Oh, so you have to deal with some admissions persons?
哦，所以你也得和招生人员打交道？
Yeah. I'm getting a little taste of my own medicine because my kid is seventh on this waiting list. And my wife the other day was like, we're going to call him every week and see where he is. I'm like, whoa, whoa, whoa. You are really flirting with the line between loving him and just really being a stalker here.
是的。我尝到了自己种下的苦果，因为我的孩子在候补名单上排第七。我妻子前几天说，我们要每周给他们打电话问问排位情况。我说，等等，等等。你这真的游走在爱他与疯狂跟踪者之间的边缘了。
So you forwarded this email that you all got. And I guess I shouldn't have been surprised by this, but I've got to say, I didn't think it-- it's from somebody whose kid is not even applying to college. It says, "Dear sir or madam, my second grader--"
你转发了你们收到的这封邮件。我想我不应该对此感到惊讶，但我得说，我没想到它会是这样的——它来自一个孩子甚至还没到申请大学年龄的人。邮件写道：“尊敬的先生或女士，我的二年级孩子——”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
I can barely finish this sentence. You know this email?
我几乎无法念完这句话。你知道这封邮件？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，当然。
"My second grader has decided on a career in electrical engineering. He is leaning towards MIT, [LAUGHS] but I do not find them helpful and would prefer a southern culture."
“我的二年级孩子已经决定从事电气工程职业。他倾向于麻省理工学院，[笑声]但我发现他们并不热心，我更倾向于南方的文化。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I like that he's playing on your pride, on your southern pride. "Would you please tell me how to prepare him for admission? He will be an Eagle Scout by then and wants to go to the best school. Please advise."
我喜欢他还在利用你的自豪感，你的南方自豪感。“请问您能告诉我如何为他的入学做准备吗？到那时他会是鹰级童子军，并且想进入最好的学校。请指教。”
Yeah. I mean, apparently MIT needs to pay more attention to seven-year-olds in their admission process.
是啊。看来麻省理工在招生过程中需要更多关注七岁的孩子了。
Rick Clark also sent me a bunch of college essays written by kids that they have gotten at Georgia Tech, again, with the names redacted. Turns out, one common mistake that kids make when they're writing their essays is that they're sending out so many applications, they leave the names of other schools in their essays to Georgia Tech.
里克·克拉克还给我发了一堆佐治亚理工收到的孩子们写的大学申请文书，同样名字已遮盖。事实证明，孩子们写文书时犯的一个常见错误是，他们申请的学校太多，结果把其他学校的名字留在发给佐治亚理工的文书中了。
All right. This is one, in fact, in a, I don't know, 14-line short essay. They twice mention a wrong school name. "So after visiting the campus, reading the information brochure, and researching the university website, I understand and believe that Duke offers what I hope to gain from my college experience."
好的。这是一篇，事实上，在大概14行的短文里，他们两次提到了错误的学校名字。“所以，在参观了校园、阅读了宣传手册并研究了大学网站后，我了解并相信杜克大学提供了我希望从大学经历中获得的一切。”
[LAUGHING] They're writing to Georgia Tech.
[笑声] 他们是写给佐治亚理工的。
And then it skips down a couple lines. And this is what really blows me away, because there's four words here separating two school names. "I've chosen to apply early decision to Georgia Tech because I believe Duke is the ideal university for me."
然后往下跳了几行。真正让我震惊的是，这里只有四个词把两个学校名字隔开了。“我选择申请佐治亚理工的提前录取，因为我相信杜克大学是我心目中的理想大学。”
Are there trends in what kids are writing about, the way you feel like you see little fads and you get sick of them?
孩子们写的内容有趋势吗？有没有那种你觉得像是小风潮，让你感到厌倦的内容？
Oh. Well, the age-old one that, I mean, again, pretty much anybody that you would interview who's been in college admission for any period of time would be-- you know, we just call it now the "mission trip" essay. And great to go on a mission trip, great to have a cultural experience, but inevitably the way it reads is so predictable.
哦。嗯，一个陈词滥调，就是那种，任何人只要采访那些在招生领域待过一段时间的人都会听到的——我们现在称之为“宣教旅行”文书。去参加宣教旅行很好，有文化体验也很好，但不可避免的是，读起来太刻板了。
We flew down to somewhere in Central America, and we got off the plane. It was really hot. And we got on the bus. And 20 miles outside of the village, our bus broke down, but we got picked up by a chicken truck and taken into town. And then over the course of my time there, I went expecting to help others, but it was, in fact, me who was changed. And even just when you first start reading that essay, you're like, oh, here it comes again.
我们飞到中美洲的某个地方，下了飞机。天气非常热。我们上了公共汽车。在离村庄20英里远的地方，我们的车坏了，但我们搭上了一辆运鸡车进了城。后来，在我待的那段时间里，我本想去帮助别人，但事实上，被改变的是我自己。甚至当你刚开始读那篇文书时，你就会想，哦，又来了。
Most college essays are pretty bad. Rick estimates that only one out of every 20 or so essays that he reads is any good at all, that is, 19 bad ones if you're counting at home. But he says that he and his colleagues believe that they themselves are partly to blame for the essay questions that they actually put onto the applications, questions that always get the same mundane, suck-uppy answers from kid, after kid, after kid. Colleges just market themselves so aggressively to so many people.
大多数大学申请文书都很糟糕。里克估计，他读的每20篇左右的文书里只有一篇还算可以，也就是说，算下来有19篇很烂。但他表示，他和同事认为，对于申请表上那些总是让孩子写出同样平庸、阿谀奉承答案的问题，他们自己也有部分责任。大学只是在如此激进地向如此多的人推销自己。
There's a girl that lives just on our street, and she's a senior this year. And she brought me over the stack of mail that she got from schools. I mean, this was just the last two months worth of mail, and it had to be two feet tall. And opening those up, I mean, they do start to just-- you put your hand over the name of the school, and it could be any place.
我们那条街上住着一个女孩，今年读高三。她把她收到的学校来信堆给我看。这只是过去两个月收到的信，得有两英尺高。打开那些信，它们真的开始变得……你只要用手遮住学校的名字，它们可能在任何地方。
It's funny when you put it that way. It's almost like the schools are being as generic in what they're saying to the students as the students are to the schools.
这样说很有趣。简直就像学校对学生说的话和学生对学校说的话一样，都是通用的套路。
That's right. Nobody puts dead squirrels on the front of their college brochure. I mean, it's all football teams winning, beautiful sunny day, kids under a tree with a professor. I mean, that's every other page. It just runs together.
没错。没人在他们的大学手册封面放死松鼠。我的意思是，全都是足球队夺冠、美丽的晴天、孩子们在树下和教授讨论。我的意思是，每隔一页就是这样。内容都混在一起了。
Rick Clark, director of admissions at Georgia Tech. Go Jackets.
里克·克拉克，佐治亚理工大学招生主任。加油，黄夹克队。
Act two, "My Ames is True." So Michael Lewis is a pretty well-known writer and reporter. His books, Moneyball, The Blind Side, and The Big Short were made into movies. His bestsellers about Wall Street include Liar's Poker and Flash Boys. But this particular story happens long before he was writing books. He was in seventh grade in New Orleans, trying to avoid reading them.
第二幕，“我的Ames是真的”。迈克尔·刘易斯是一位相当知名的作家和记者。他的作品《点球成金》、《弱点》和《大空头》都被拍成了电影。他关于华尔街的畅销书包括《说谎者的扑克牌》和《闪电男孩》。但这个特定的故事发生在他写书很久以前。当时他在新奥尔良上七年级，正试图避免阅读那些书。
And the English teacher, Mr. Downer, asked us to write a book report on a novel called Johnny Tremain. And I went home and I looked at the book. And I noticed on the back-- there was this great book report with the book, and it was just on the back of the book.
英语老师唐纳先生（Mr. Downer）要求我们写一篇关于小说《约翰尼·特里梅因》（Johnny Tremain）的书评。我回家看了看这本书。我注意到书的封底——上面有一篇很棒的书评，就在封底上。
Oh, you mean a little summary?
哦，你是说一段小摘要？
Little summary. And I just copied it out and handed it in and [INAUDIBLE] with it. It came back with an A on it. And it says, "See me" on the top in big red ink. And I go to see Mr. Downer, and he says, that's plagiarism. Oh, my god. What's plagiarism?
小摘要。我就把它抄下来交上去了，而且[听不清]混过去了。作业发回来时上面打了个A。上面用红色大号字体写着“来找我”。我去找唐纳先生，他说，这是剽窃。天哪。剽窃是什么？
You had never heard of it?
你从没听说过这个词？
Never heard of it. And the concept was alien to me. I mean, I just thought it was an odd concept because you repeat what other people say all the time. I was just repeating what someone else said. It just seemed like a very intelligent thing to repeat. And I was telling him this. I thought I was saving us all a lot of trouble.
从来没听说过。这个概念对我来说很陌生。我的意思是，我只是觉得这是一个奇怪的概念，因为你一直在重复别人说过的话。我只是重复了别人说过的话。这似乎是一件非常明智的重复行为。我当时就是这么跟他说的。我觉得我是在帮我们俩省麻烦。
Saving us trouble, like?
帮我们省麻烦，比如？
It'll save him the trouble of reading something really awful. And I wouldn't have to write a boring book report or even read the boring book. I was doing both of us a favor. And it seemed kind of counterintuitive to have to generate a thing that had already been done.
能省去他阅读一些糟糕内容的麻烦。我也不用写枯燥的书评，甚至不用读枯燥的书。我是在帮我们俩的忙。而且，去写一篇已经有人写过的东西，似乎有点不合逻辑。
Mr. Downer does not agree, and the middle school principal decides to expel Michael.
唐纳先生不这么认为，初中校长决定开除迈克尔。
And at this point, do you understand what's wrong with what you've done?
那在这个时候，你明白你做错什么了吗？
No, I'm indignant. I understand I'm supposed to feel it's wrong, but I don't feel it's wrong.
没有，我很愤慨。我明白我应该觉得那是错的，但我并不觉得那是错的。
Michael Lewis says, by the way, if you are a seventh grader hearing us talk about this right now and you want to try this with one of his books in your classroom, you totally have his blessing. He wishes you the best, though he is pretty sure you're going to get the same results that he did. Anyway, ultimately, his parents get involved. Seventh grade Michael Lewis is not expelled from school.
顺便说一下，迈克尔·刘易斯说，如果有七年级的学生现在正在听我们谈论这个，并且想在课堂上用他的书尝试一下，他完全支持。他祝你们好运，尽管他很确定你们会得到和他一样的结果。总之，最后他的父母介入了。七年级的迈克尔·刘易斯没有被学校开除。
But what I have to do is write 100 times a phrase that Mr. Downer has written on the blackboard, "I will not plagiarize the work of others."
但我必须写100遍唐纳先生在黑板上写的那句话：“我不会剽窃他人的作品。”
Wait.
等等。
The punishment is to plagiarize 100 times, over, and over, and over. And I didn't understand really the point of this because I thought, well, this is just plagiarizing again. And if this is the way they just want to show me that it's supposed to be harder work to plagiarize, that was it.
惩罚就是剽窃100遍，一遍又一遍，一遍又一遍。我真的不明白这样做的意义，因为我想，这不又是剽窃吗？如果这是他们想要向我展示剽窃应该是更艰苦的工作的方式，那也仅此而已了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This has become one of the stories that Michael has found himself telling now and then over the years.
这成了迈克尔多年来偶尔会讲起的故事之一。
Every now and then, I wheel it out. And at some point, it occurred to me that the mere fact I like this story says an awful lot about me.
时不时地，我会把它拿出来讲。在某个时刻，我意识到我仅仅因为喜欢这个故事，就足以说明我很多问题了。
And so what does this one say about you?
那这一个故事说明了你什么呢？
Well, I think it rhymes with sort of my worldview and the general sense that authority is often absurd, a general sense that punishments often don't fit crimes, a general sense that often things that are supposed to be wrong don't actually feel wrong, and maybe they aren't as wrong as people say.
嗯，我认为它与我的世界观很契合，比如权威通常是荒谬的，惩罚通常不符合罪行，通常被认为是错的事情其实并不觉得错，也许它们并没有人们说的那么严重。
You know, we all have certain stories from our childhoods that we trot out from time to time, out of all the thousands of things that ever happened to us. And usually, it's not many stories that we'll actually trot out, right? And the choices that we make, you know, the selection that we make of which incidents we find ourselves telling people, it says so much about us and how we see the world, which ones we pick.
你知道，我们童年时代都有一些时不时拿出来讲的故事，在成千上万件发生在我们身上的事情中。通常，我们真正拿出来讲的故事并不多，对吧？我们做出的选择，我们挑选哪些事件讲给别人听，这说明了我们很多问题，包括我们如何看待这个世界。
And I bring all this up because the actual real story that Michael Lewis is here on the radio show today to report is a very good example of that. Of course, this is our "How I Got Into College" show, so this is the story of how one guy, named Emir Kamenica, got into college, but it's also an illustration of this other thing. Anyway, here's Michael.
我提到这一切是因为迈克尔·刘易斯今天来电台报道的真实故事，就是一个很好的例子。当然，这是我们的“我是如何考上大学的”节目，所以这是关于一个叫埃米尔·卡门尼卡（Emir Kamenica）的家伙如何考上大学的故事，但它也是说明这另一件事的一个案例。总之，有请迈克尔。
I think if I were telling you Emir's story, I'd probably just start at the very beginning, how he was born in Bosnia in 1978, how he grew up in Sarajevo with loving parents and a happy family. But it's his story, so let's let him tell it the way he tells it.
我想，如果是我来讲埃米尔的故事，我可能会从最开始讲起，他1978年出生在波斯尼亚，在萨拉热窝成长，有慈爱的父母和幸福的家庭。但这毕竟是他的故事，还是让他按他自己的方式来讲吧。
All right. Well, I guess the natural place to start the story might just be the outset of the war. I was 13 at the time. The war, from my perspective, because I wasn't particularly paying attention to the political situation, comes truly out of nowhere. It's sort of one morning, you wake up expecting the world will look just the way it did yesterday, and instead there are these people in leather jackets with stockings on their heads and machine guns in their hands.
好的。嗯，我想故事的自然起点也许就是战争爆发的时候。我当时13岁。从我的角度来看，因为我并没有特别注意政治局势，战争简直是凭空发生的。就像那天早上醒来时，你期望世界看起来和昨天一样，结果却出现了那些穿着皮夹克、头上套着丝袜、手里拿着机关枪的人。
So the Serb troops hadn't gotten to his neighborhood yet. And one Sunday, his mother took Emir and his sister across the river to visit his great aunt. The walk was about a mile.
所以塞尔维亚军队当时还没到他的社区。一个周日，他母亲带着埃米尔和他姐姐过河去探望他的一位姨婆。路程大约一英里。
So when we realized this might not have been a good idea is that we start crossing this bridge, some shooting starts. And it's clear some people are shooting at us because you can see the bullets ricochet around. And we just kind of run.
所以当我们意识到这可能不是个好主意时，我们开始过桥，枪声响了。很明显有人在向我们射击，因为你可以看到子弹在周围弹跳。我们就只能跑。
They managed to get to the other side of the bridge without getting shot, but they couldn't go back. And his dad was trapped back where they lived. The Serb troops ended up killing a lot of the men in Emir's old neighborhood and raping the women. But when Emir tells the story, he stresses just how lucky they were to get out, for example, how lucky they were to hitch a ride from two women, complete strangers, and to join a convoy of 5,000 Bosnian refugees, all of them women and children fleeing for the Croatian coast, how lucky it was that they owned a camper near the beach where they spent the summers, how lucky it was that it was May, when the weather was warm, how lucky they were even after the weather turned cold and their camper became uninhabitable.
他们设法跑到了桥的另一边，没有中弹，但他们回不去了。他父亲被困在他们住的地方。塞尔维亚军队最终杀害了埃米尔旧社区里的许多男人，并强奸了妇女。但当埃米尔讲这个故事时，他强调了他们是多么幸运才逃了出来。例如，他们是多么幸运，搭上了两个完全陌生女人的顺风车，加入了5000名波斯尼亚难民的队伍，那些人全都是逃往克罗地亚海岸的妇女和儿童；是多么幸运，他们在海滩附近有一个夏天度假用的露营车；多么幸运，当时是五月，天气温暖；多么幸运，即使在天气变冷、他们的露营车变得无法居住后……
Which was actually another pure, fortuitous coincidence. My mother happened to be in a market and ran across a woman who was my sister's homeroom teacher in Sarajevo.
这实际上是另一个纯粹的偶然巧合。我母亲当时恰好在市场里，遇到了我姐姐在萨拉热窝时的班主任。
This woman happened to be moving to London and needed someone to watch her apartment, more good luck. Clearly, there was some bad luck too, but Emir doesn't mention it. I have to prod him to fill in the piece of the story he most obviously leaves out.
这位女士恰好要搬去伦敦，需要有人看管她的公寓，真是好运。显然也有坏运气，但埃米尔没有提。我不得不催促他填补这个故事中他最明显省略的部分。
So let me stop you for a second.
那让我打断你一下。
Yeah. Sorry, go on.
好，抱歉，请继续。
I was going to ask you, do you know exactly what happened to your father?
我本来想问你，你确切知道你父亲发生了什么事吗？
I don't know exactly what happened. What I do know is that a neighbor of ours, a person who lived in our high rise, he found my father's body on the street, and he took him to the local cemetery and buried him. So we at least do know where he is.
我不确切知道发生了什么。但我知道的是，我们的一位邻居，一个住在我们那栋楼里的人，他在街上找到了我父亲的遗体，并把他带到当地的墓地埋葬了。所以我们至少知道他在哪里。
Anyway, Emir and his mom and his sister moved into this apartment in a city crawling with hostile Croat nationalists. His mother wasn't allowed to work. And before long, Emir and his sister weren't allowed to go to school.
总之，埃米尔和他的妈妈以及姐姐搬进了这间公寓，身处在一座满是敌对的克罗地亚民族主义者的城市里。他母亲不允许工作。没过多久，埃米尔和他姐姐也不允许去上学了。
When he went outside, Emir would be chased by these thugs who wanted to beat him up just because he was Muslim. His family wasn't even faintly religious, so he thought this was especially bizarre. He was stuck inside this apartment. In his telling, he did almost nothing but read books.
当他到外面时，埃米尔会遭到那些暴徒的追赶，他们想揍他，仅仅因为他是穆斯林。他的家庭甚至一点宗教信仰都没有，所以他觉得这尤其不可思议。他被困在公寓里。在他的讲述中，他几乎什么都不做，只读书。
So I would get the books from the local library. I would sort of run there to make sure I don't encounter any of the nationalists that are trying to prove their patriotism by beating me up.
所以我会从当地图书馆借书。我会跑过去，确保不会遇到那些试图通过揍我来证明爱国主义的民族主义者。
And I'm trying to picture this, actually. So you're actually running through the streets with library books under your arms and running back with other library books under your arms?
我正在试着想象这个画面。所以你真的胳膊下夹着图书馆的书跑过街道，然后又胳膊下夹着其他的图书馆书跑回来？
Yeah. It was library books. I also tried to teach myself a few things. Because eventually, you get bored of reading novels, so I tried to learn some more physics. I read a lot of Freud, which I decided was not that good.
是的，是图书馆的书。我也尝试自学一些东西。因为最终，读小说读腻了，所以我尝试学习一些物理。我读了很多弗洛伊德，我觉得那并不怎么样。
And one of the books I read was called The Fortress, by an author called Mesa Selimovic. And I do not know why. I guess, 15, I was impressionable. I was very much moved by that novel.
我读的一本书叫《堡垒》（The Fortress），作者是梅萨·塞利莫维奇（Mesa Selimovic）。我不知道为什么。我想，15岁，我很容易受影响。我非常被那本小说感动。
I've never actually read The Fortress. But according to the description on the back of the book, it's about a young man who, quote, "overcomes the psychological anguish of war, only to find that he has emerged a reflective and contemplative man in a society that does not value the subversive implications of these qualities." Emir loved the book. He read it over and over.
我从来没读过《堡垒》。但根据书封底的介绍，它讲述了一个年轻人，“克服了战争带来的心理痛苦，最终发现自己变成了一个反思和沉思的人，而在一个不重视这些品质的颠覆性意义的社会里。”埃米尔喜欢这本书。他一遍又一遍地阅读。
One day, his mother announces that they'd had another lucky break. Out of a million Bosnian refugees, they are among the first few thousand being handed tickets to the United States. They packed to leave, but all Emir has is some T-shirts, blue jeans, and this library book.
有一天，他母亲宣布他们又有了个好运气。在一百万波斯尼亚难民中，他们是第一批获得美国签证的几千人之一。他们收拾行李离开，但埃米尔只有几件T恤、蓝牛仔裤和这本图书馆的书。
Which is still in my room. And so when we're packing to leave, I decide to bring it with me to the US as my most prized possession.
这书现在还在我房间里。所以当我们打包离开时，我决定把它带到美国，作为我最珍贵的财产。
So when you take this book, are you sensitive to the fact you're stealing a library book?
所以当你拿走这本书时，你是否意识到你在偷图书馆的书？
I am entirely aware of that, yeah. I didn't feel like the community or the town had treated me very nicely, so I perhaps had less guilt than I might have in other circumstances.
我完全意识到了，是的。我觉得这个社区或这个城镇并没有对我很好，所以我可能比在其他情况下少了一点愧疚感。
The UN dropped Emir and his mom and his sister in Atlanta, which was as good as any other place since they didn't know a soul in the entire country. They were picked up at the Atlanta airport along with an older Bosnian couple they don't know at all and taken to their new home.
联合国把埃米尔和他妈妈、姐姐空投到了亚特兰大，由于他们在整个国家一个熟人都不认识，这里和任何其他地方一样好。他们在亚特兰大机场和一对不认识的波斯尼亚老夫妇一起被接走，带到了他们的新家。
And we pull into this apartment complex. And I remember very well when the van stopped, I just saw this look of terror on my mother and sister's faces. So I immediately turned to them, reassuring, said, oh, no, no, no. They're not dropping us off here. This is just where this couple is going. We're going elsewhere.
我们开进了这个公寓区。我清楚地记得货车停下时，我看到我母亲和姐姐脸上的恐惧。所以我立刻转向她们，安慰说，噢，不，不，不。他们不是要把我们丢在这里。这只是那对夫妇要去的地方。我们要去别处。
So the guy opened the door. The other couple got out. And I just sort of, with my hand, signaled to my mother and sister to sit still because surely, surely this is not where we're going. But in fact, that was where we were going, and it's just horrible. There's cockroaches running all over the place.
所以那个人打开门。那对夫妇下车了。我用手势示意母亲和姐姐坐好，因为肯定、肯定这不是我们要去的地方。但事实上，这确实是我们要去的地方，简直太可怕了。到处都是蟑螂。
So far as he could tell, there weren't any other white people in the neighborhood. And to Emir, this whole black people, white people thing was an entirely new experience. But the first thing that struck him was that the black people didn't really seem to like the white people very much.
据他所见，这个社区里没有任何其他白人。对埃米尔来说，这种黑人白人的事情是全新的体验。但第一件让他震惊的事是，黑人似乎不太喜欢白人。
Which was particularly ironic, given that, first, I don't know that I'm Muslim. All of a sudden, people try and kill me because they think I'm Muslim. I did not know I was white. Now, all of a sudden, these kids want to beat me up because I'm white.
这尤其具有讽刺意味，因为第一，我不知道我是穆斯林。突然之间，人们因为认为我是穆斯林而试图杀我。我不知道我是白人。现在，突然之间，这些孩子因为我是白人而想揍我。
Once again, he couldn't leave his home without feeling a little bit scared, even when he went to school, which was called Clarkston High. Sitting in his literature class one day, Emir heard a kid get shot right outside the classroom.
再一次，他出门就会感到一点害怕，即使去上学，那个学校叫克拉克斯顿高中（Clarkston High）。有一天坐在文学课上，埃米尔听到一个孩子在教室外面被枪击了。
The teacher was reading out loud from Romeo and Juliet at the time. I'm not sure if others noticed the kind of appropriateness. There was lots of racial tension. I was one of, I would guess, like 12 or 20 white kids in a school of 900. There were lots of fights, lots of fighting.
老师当时正在朗读《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。我不确定其他人是否注意到了那种讽刺感。当时有很多种族紧张关系。在900人的学校里，我估计我是那12到20个白人孩子之一。有很多斗殴，很多打架。
Probably the worst class of all, by far, was this biology class. And the teacher there-- this was, I think, his first year of teaching. And he did not have any method for controlling the students.
可能最糟的一门课是生物课。老师——我觉得这是他教书的第一年。他没有任何控制学生的方法。
So one day, he brought a bunny to class, but the other students decided that it would be much more entertaining to use the bunny as a soccer ball. So they would just kick the bunny around while the teacher sort of ran around the classroom, trying to stop this. The bunny survived, but it looked like he'd gone blind. One of his eyes was completely mangled.
有一天，他带了一只兔子到课堂上，但其他学生决定把兔子当足球踢会更有趣。于是他们就踢那只兔子，而老师在教室里跑来跑去试图阻止这一切。兔子活下来了，但看起来它瞎了。它的一只眼睛完全被弄坏了。
In those first few months, Emir made just a single friend, another Bosnian refugee named Emil. Emir and Emil were inseparable, but they were joined mainly by their fear of everyone else.
在最初的几个月里，埃米尔只交了一个朋友，另一个叫埃米尔（Emil）的波斯尼亚难民。埃米尔和埃米尔形影不离，但他们聚在一起主要是因为对其他所有人的恐惧。
And how is your English at this point?
那时候你的英语怎么样？
Terrible.
太差了。
That was another problem. He says he couldn't really talk to the other kids or his teachers, and so he sort of walked around the school in silence, like a mute. To improve his English, he returned to The Fortress, the novel he'd stolen from the Croatian library. At night, he'd sit down with a dictionary and translate The Fortress from Bosnian to English.
那是另一个问题。他说他无法真正与同学或老师交谈，所以他就像个哑巴一样在学校里默默地走来走去。为了提高英语，他回到了《堡垒》，那本他从克罗地亚图书馆偷来的书。晚上，他拿着字典，把《堡垒》从波斯尼亚语翻译成英语。
It was useful because it did improve my English, and it also gave me the sense of sort of-- it made me feel literary. It made me feel like I was creating something beautiful.
这很有用，因为它提高了我的英语，也给我一种……它让我感到文学气息。它让我觉得我在创造某种美丽的东西。
So he was back to sitting alone in his room with his novel. But as Emir tells it, all of this really just set the stage for his biggest stroke of luck, the one that would not only get him into college, but would change his entire life. It came in the form of a teacher who descended for maybe two weeks upon his English classroom. Emir remembers only her last name, Ames, Miss Ames. Or maybe it was Mrs. Ames.
所以他回到了独自坐在房间里读小说的日子。但在埃米尔看来，所有这些其实都为他最大的好运奠定了基础，那次好运不仅让他考上了大学，还改变了他的一生。那是以一位在他的英语教室里可能只待了两周的老师的形式出现的。埃米尔只记得她的姓，艾姆斯（Ames），艾姆斯小姐。或者可能是艾姆斯夫人。
He thinks she was an intern training to be a teacher. Anyway, she wasn't around for very long. Unlike his regular teacher, she was full of energy. She tried all these new tricks to engage their interest.
他认为她是一位实习老师。总之，她待的时间不长。和他的常规老师不同，她充满活力。她尝试了各种新花样来吸引他们的兴趣。
One day, she handed out these photographs to the kids. The one she gave to Emir was of a boy with a haunted look on his face, looking over his shoulder. Then she told them all to write an essay about the pictures.
有一天，她给孩子们发了照片。给埃米尔的那张照片是一个看起来眼神恍惚、回头看的男孩。然后她让所有人都写一篇关于照片的文章。
Write an essay-- that's a pretty difficult thing for me, given my limited knowledge of English. So first thought, I'm going to dread this task. But then I realized, there's this really beautiful passage, this beautiful chapter I had translated, I had worked on the previous night from The Fortress. So I decide to, pretty much, word for word replicate this passage and use that as my essay for Miss Ames.
写文章——考虑到我有限的英语知识，这是一个非常艰巨的任务。所以第一个想法是，我害怕这项任务。但随后我意识到，有一段非常美丽的段落，那本美丽的章节我翻译过，前一天晚上我一直在研究《堡垒》。所以我决定，几乎逐字逐句地复制这一段，并把它当作写给艾姆斯小姐的文章。
I still remember a little bit about what the passage was about. The protagonist has witnessed an injustice. I remember I closed my essay with this bit of internal monologue, which roughly says, "I'm slowly becoming a repository for decomposing sorrows, regrets, ignored injustice, forgotten promises. I can still feel its stench. But when I get accustomed to it, I will call it experience." And I think Miss Ames was impressed.
我还记得一点那段话的内容。主角目睹了一场不公。我记得我在文章结尾加上了这段内心独白，大意是：“我正在慢慢成为分解的悲伤、遗憾、被忽视的不公、被遗忘的承诺的储存库。我依然能感觉到它的恶臭。但当我习惯了它，我就会称之为经验。”我想艾姆斯小姐印象深刻。
And since The Fortress had never been translated into English, there was exactly zero chance she'd ever catch him.
而且由于《堡垒》从未被翻译成英文，她永远不可能发现他在剽窃。
What happened is, the next day, Miss Ames walks up to me and pretty much whispers into my ear, you have to get out of this school, which is not what you typically expect teachers to tell you in school. But I'm like, yeah, where? Where do I go?
结果是，第二天，艾姆斯小姐走到我身边，几乎在我耳边低语，你必须离开这所学校，这通常不是你在学校里预期老师会告诉你的话。但我回答，是啊，去哪？我去哪儿？
And she said, well, you know, there are private schools. I was like, well, don't those cost money? She says, well, some of them have financial aid. In fact, I have a job interview at a very nice private school on Monday. Why don't you just come with me and ask whether they have financial aid? And I was like, OK.
她说，嗯，你知道，有私立学校。我回答说，嗯，那些不需要钱吗？她说，嗯，有些学校有经济援助。事实上，我周一要去一所非常好的私立学校进行工作面试。你为什么不跟我一起去，问问他们是否有经济援助呢？我说，好的。
So the following Monday, instead of going to Clarkston High in the morning, Miss Ames comes to pick me up at our apartment complex. And she drives me to midtown Atlanta to this just beautiful, wonderful school with manicured lawns. It just looks lovely.
所以接下来的周一，艾姆斯小姐没有让我去克拉克斯顿高中，而是来我们的公寓区接我。她开车带我去了亚特兰大市区一所非常漂亮、美妙的学校，有修剪整齐的草坪。看起来太美了。
This new place is called The Paideia School. He's never heard of it.
这个新地方叫派地亚学校（The Paideia School）。他从未听说过它。
So she goes to have her job interview, and I go to the admissions office. And there's the admissions officer. So she's sort of looking at me as sort of, so? And I remember pretty distinctly, I said, I am a Bosnian refugee. My school is really bad. Can I please go here?
于是她去面试，我去了招生办。招生官坐在那里。她打量着我，像是在说，所以呢？我记得很清楚，我说，我是波斯尼亚难民。我的学校真的很糟。请问我能来这里上学吗？
You'd memorized that sentence?
你背下了那句话？
I think I had practiced it ahead of time. So it's stuck in my head because I had kind of planned this great pitch that I had, which is, I'm a Bosnian refugee. My school is really bad. Can I please go here?
我想我提前练习过。所以它卡在脑子里，因为我已经设计好了这个伟大的推销词，也就是，我是波斯尼亚难民。我的学校真的很糟。请问我能来这里上学吗？
She points out to me that applications were due three months ago. She asked whether I need financial aid. I asked how much it would be. She said something, which to me, was equivalent to a bazillion dollars. So I said, yes, I need financial aid. She points out those were given out six months ago.
她指出申请截止日期是三个月前。她问我是否需要经济援助。我问需要多少钱。她说了一个数字，对我来说相当于一万亿。所以我说，是的，我需要经济援助。她指出那些援助在六个月前就发完了。
She then suggests maybe I should think about applying for the following year. And to that, I retort, I'm a Bosnian refugee. My school is really, really bad. Can I please, please go here? And I guess that was effective, particularly in conjunction with the essay, which Miss Ames brought to her job interview, so that when she was asked why she wanted to be a teacher, she pulls out this essay and says, because of children like these.
然后她建议也许我应该考虑申请下一年。对此，我反驳道，我是波斯尼亚难民。我的学校真的、真的很糟。请问我能来这里上学吗？我猜这很有效，特别是结合了艾姆斯小姐在她工作面试中带去的文章，所以当她被问到为什么想当老师时，她掏出这篇文章说，就是为了像这样的孩子。
These children who plagiarize essays from stolen library books.
这些从偷来的图书馆书里剽窃文章的孩子。
She didn't know that.
她当时并不知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Unbeknownst to me at the time, Paideia is the most PC, diversity-obsessed school south of the Mason-Dixon line. I mean, they really think diversity is important. And a Bosnian refugee, at this time, now that's a very rare commodity. So they basically managed to dig up some money.
当时我不知道，派地亚学校是梅森-迪克森线以南最讲究政治正确、最沉迷于多元化的学校。我的意思是，他们真的认为多元化很重要。而在当时，一个波斯尼亚难民是一个非常罕见的商品。所以他们基本上设法挤出了一些钱。
I was there sophomore, junior, and senior year of high school. And it was a lovely place. It was a heaven on earth, as far as I was concerned. All the teachers went by their first names. We had couches instead of desks in the classrooms. I mean, not just was the school good, I also felt safe. And this feeling of safety had been lacking for the previous few years.
我在那所高中待了高二、高三和高三。那是个可爱的地方。对我而言，那是人间天堂。所有老师都按名字称呼。教室里我们用沙发代替课桌。我的意思是，学校不仅好，我也感到安全。这种安全感在过去几年里一直缺失。
And I think it does something to you. I think you have new resources to pay attention to things about the world which are beautiful, things about the world which are interesting, things about the world which are intriguing. I'm speculating here, but I think you're somewhere, at a deep level, distracted by the threat. I could instead focus on catching up on the things I hadn't learned.
我认为它会对你产生影响。我想你有新的资源去关注这个世界上美丽、有趣、引人入胜的事物。我在这里推测，但在某种深层面上，你被威胁分散了精力。我可以转而专注于补上我还没学到的东西。
Four years later, he was a student at Harvard on a scholarship that paid for tuition, room, and board. From there, he went and got his PhD in economics, also from Harvard. At Harvard, he met his future wife. And from Harvard, he went to the University of Chicago, which gave him tenure at a young age. And he's now a rising star in the field of behavioral economics, all because Miss Ames read his plagiarized essay and was fooled by it.
四年后，他成了哈佛大学的学生，拿到了支付学费、食宿费的奖学金。从那里，他继续攻读哈佛大学的经济学博士。在哈佛，他遇到了未来的妻子。从哈佛，他去了芝加哥大学，并在年轻时获得了终身教职。他现在是行为经济学领域冉冉升起的新星，这一切都因为艾姆斯小姐读了他剽窃的文章，并被它欺骗了。
I mean, it is by far the-- in everyone's life, there are many forks. This is by far the biggest one. This has made the most difference. I mean, there's no doubt that my life got onto a very different kind of a track.
我的意思是，这是我人生中最大的转折点。没有任何疑问，我的人生进入了完全不同的轨道。
And I'm pretty sure that if it hadn't been for her, I would have stayed in Clarkston High School. I wouldn't have thought to apply to a private school. I most certainly wouldn't have gone to Harvard. And she gave me a piece of paper and a pen 10 years ago and said, OK, describe what you think of as the most wonderful life. I think I'd come up with something less good than what it actually is.
我很确定，如果不是因为她，我会一直待在克拉克斯顿高中。我不会想到去申请私立学校。我肯定不会去哈佛。她十年前给了我一张纸和一支笔说，好吧，描述一下你认为最美妙的生活。我想我写出来的会比实际情况差。
It's always hard to say how your life would have turned out differently if something hadn't happened to you. But in Emir's case, there's at least one useful reference point, his Bosnian friend, Emil. Emil hadn't been airlifted out of Clarkston into some fancy private school. Instead, he dropped out of Clarkston, done some bad things, and actually spent some time in jail. Eventually, he went back to Bosnia-- no Miss Ames, no rescue.
如果某些事情没发生在你身上，你的人生会有什么不同，这总是很难说。但在埃米尔的例子中，至少有一个有用的参考点，他的波斯尼亚朋友埃米尔（Emil）。埃米尔没有被空运出克拉克斯顿去什么高级私立学校。相反，他从克拉克斯顿辍学，做了一些坏事，甚至坐了牢。最终，他回到了波斯尼亚——没有艾姆斯小姐，没有救援。
Over the years, Emir's told this story a lot. It might be his favorite story that he tells about himself. It rhymes with his view of the world, that there's just this huge, accidental component to life's outcomes, that everyone owes at least some of their success not just to chance, but to other people being nice for no reason at all.
这些年来，埃米尔经常讲这个故事。这可能是他讲的关于自己最喜欢的故事。它与他对世界的看法相符，即生活的结果存在巨大的偶然性，每个人不仅要归功于运气，还要归功于其他人无缘无故地善待他们。
What became of Miss Ames?
艾姆斯小姐后来怎么样了？
I don't know. Turned out she didn't get the job at Paideia, so I never saw her again at Paideia. In fact, I never saw her again.
我不知道。结果她没得到派地亚的工作，所以我再也没在派地亚见过她。事实上，我再也没见过她。
At some point, the fact that Emir had no idea what had happened to this woman who'd changed his entire life started to bother him. It's as if the more he told the story, the more grateful he became. And the more grateful he became, the more he wanted to find her, to thank her, but also just to show her the life he had because of her.
在某个时刻，埃米尔不知道那个改变了他一生的女人发生了什么事，这开始困扰他。好像他讲这个故事越多，他就越感激。他越感激，就越想找到她，感谢她，也向她展示他因为她而拥有的生活。
He Googled around for her, but then realized he didn't have any idea how to spell her name. He pestered both of his old schools, but neither of them had any record of her. No one even remembered her. His investigations, such as they were, were sort of half-assed, but what was he going to do? Hire a private eye?
他在谷歌上搜索过她，但后来意识到他根本不知道怎么拼她的名字。他缠着两所老学校问，但两所都没有她的记录。甚至没人记得她。他的调查，充其量只是半吊子，但他能怎么办？雇私家侦探？
My name is Irving Botwinick, and my business is called Serving by Irving.
我叫欧文·博特威尼克（Irving Botwinick），我的业务叫“欧文服务”（Serving by Irving）。
So you specialize in finding people?
所以你专门负责找人？
That's what we do. We dig them up. Actually, we have a motto. If they're alive, we serve them. If they're dead, we'll tell you where they're buried.
我们就是做这个的。我们把他们挖出来。事实上，我们有个座右铭。如果他们活着，我们就找到他们。如果他们死了，我们会告诉你他们埋在哪里。
Irving's a private detective who serves lots of court papers. Since Emir wasn't going to hire one, This American Life did it for him.
欧文是一位私家侦探，专门处理法院文件。由于埃米尔没打算雇人，《美国生活》为他雇了。
All right, so we have somebody we need to find.
好的，我们有人需要找到。
OK.
好的。
All right. [CLEARS THROAT] So the person that I'd like to find is called Miss Ames. Not sure how to spell that. I have reasons to think, I can mention later, that she was married, at least the last time I saw her, which was in 1993 in Atlanta, Georgia.
好的。[清嗓子] 所以我想找的人叫艾姆斯小姐。不确定怎么拼。我有理由认为，以后可以提，她结婚了，至少在我最后一次见到她时，那是在1993年的佐治亚州亚特兰大。
Emir went on to explain in great detail that he knew basically nothing about her-- height, weight, eye color, all a mystery. When Irving asked him what she looked like, he said, quote, "She was neither particularly skinny, nor fat. Not particularly short, nor tall. She looked normal," he said. About the only thing he remembers about her is what she'd done for him. Irving thought the full-time English teacher would be a good place to start, but Emir didn't remember her name either.
埃米尔详细解释说，他基本上对她一无所知——身高、体重、眼睛颜色，全是谜。当欧文问她长什么样时，他说，原文是，“她既不算特别瘦，也不胖。不算特别矮，也不高。她看起来很正常，”他说。关于她，他唯一记得的就是她为他做的事情。欧文认为全职英语老师是个好的起点，但埃米尔也不记得那个人的名字。
Did you have a class book for that year?
那一年你有班级纪念册吗？
Oh, no. No.
哦，没有。没有。
Somehow, Irving seemed to find what Emir was saying useful. He wrote little notes to himself about what I do not know. But at the top of the page, he wrote Miss Ames. Then he wrote a big question mark. Then he asked Emir to go away and write down everything he could remember from that period of his life. But before he lifted a finger to find Miss Ames he said, he needed to do a character check on Emir.
不知何故，欧文似乎觉得埃米尔说的话很有用。他记了一些关于我不了解情况的笔记。但在页面顶部，他写了“艾姆斯小姐”。然后他写了一个大问号。然后他让埃米尔离开，把那段生活经历里能记住的一切写下来。但在他动动手指寻找艾姆斯小姐之前，他说，他需要对埃米尔进行背景调查。
Because a lot of times, investigators get cases where they're trying to track somebody down, and then they go and they kill them. So we have to sort of verify what you're telling us is the truth as well.
因为很多时候，调查员接到案子试图追踪某人，结果对方把他们杀了。所以我们也得验证你告诉我们的是事实。
So Irving, let's just assume that the facts are as bare as they sound. Is it hopeless?
那么欧文，让我们假设事实确实如听起来的那样简单。这没希望了吗？
No. There's nobody I can't find, I'll put it that way. I could have found Osama bin Laden if they paid me enough to do it.
没有。没有什么人是我找不到的，我就这么说吧。如果他们付钱足够多，我连奥萨马·本·拉登都能找到。
So how long do you need to do your search? When can we expect to be sitting down in a room with Miss Ames?
那么你需要多长时间来搜寻？我们什么时候能期待和艾姆斯小姐坐在一个房间里？
Oh, probably before the end of the month, before the end of February.
哦，可能在本月底之前，二月底之前。
The end of February came and went. March came and went too, without the slightest trace of Miss Ames. It wasn't for lack of trying. Irving had put his best agent on the case, a woman named Gabriela Galindo. The first thing Gabriela did was to try the public school, but only two teachers who had been there in 1993 were still around.
二月底过去了。三月也过去了，没有艾姆斯小姐的半点踪迹。这并不是因为没有尝试。欧文把他最好的特工派去处理这个案子，一个叫加布里埃拉·加林多（Gabriela Galindo）的女士。加布里埃拉做的第一件事是尝试联系那所公立学校，但只有两名1993年就在那里的老师还在学校。
And they had no recollection of not even the English teacher, not even the English teacher.
他们根本没有回忆，甚至连英语老师是谁都不记得。
She hired a local detective to go to Clarkston to get the yearbook, but they wouldn't give him one. She learned that the Georgia Department of Education keeps a list of all the teachers ever certified in the state, but she couldn't get access to the list. She called nearby colleges to search lists of graduates from the 1990s, still no sign of Miss Ames. Out of desperation, she hunted down all the old phone books from the region from the 1990s.
她雇了一名当地侦探去克拉克斯顿拿纪念册，但他们不给。她得知佐治亚州教育部保留了一份在该州获得过认证的所有老师名单，但她无法查阅该名单。她给附近的学院打电话搜索1990年代的毕业生名单，还是没有艾姆斯小姐的踪影。绝望中，她搜寻了1990年代该地区所有的旧电话簿。
These are copies of the phone books that we received going back from 1990 to 1993 of all the people in the greater Atlanta area with the last name Ames, which is a very, very common name, we found.
这些是我们收到的从1990年到1993年大亚特兰大地区所有姓Ames的人的电话簿副本，我们发现这是一个非常、非常常见的名字。
Yeah.
是的。
Very common.
非常常见。
And roughly, how many people were there?
大概有多少人？
Oh, my god. Oh, hundreds.
哦，天哪。几百个。
And you weren't even sure her name was Ames.
而且你甚至不确定她姓Ames。
Correct. That's the other thing. That's the other thing. We weren't sure.
没错。那是另一回事。那是另一回事。我们不确定。
They called every Ames on the list, all these hundreds of names. Still didn't find her. And it was starting to feel just a little bit weird. A lot of the people Irving goes hunting for don't want to be found, but he finds them anyway. Here was someone with no obvious reason not to want to be found, and she'd vanished without a trace.
他们打了名单上所有Ames的电话。还是没找到她。这开始让人觉得有点诡异了。欧文追捕的很多人都不想被找到，但他总是能找到。这里有一个人没有明显理由不想被找到，而她却消失得无影无踪。
After a couple of months of this, you couldn't help but wonder, why was this woman the most difficult person on Earth to find? Was it because she wasn't an earthly creature? Not once, but twice this boy had found himself in a world more intent on destroying him than in building him up. Maybe he needed evidence that people weren't all bad. Maybe that's where angels always come from.
几个月后，你不禁会想，为什么这个女人是地球上最难找的人？难道是因为她不是凡人？这个男孩不仅一次，而是两次发现自己身处一个更想摧毁他而不是培养他的世界里。也许他需要证据证明人们并不全是坏的。也许这就是天使总是来自的地方。
Is this Miss Ames?
这是艾姆斯小姐吗？
Yes, it is.
是的，是。
Oh, my goodness. It's like finding a ghost, finding you. It's a pleasure to hear your voice.
哦，天哪。就像找到一个幽灵，找到你。听到你的声音真是太荣幸了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's just the two of us talking. Emir isn't in the conversation yet.
现在只有我们两个在对话。埃米尔还没加入谈话。
I'm going to call you Miss Ames, because I don't want to think of you as anything but Miss Ames.
我要叫你艾姆斯小姐，因为我不想想到你时，除了艾姆斯小姐什么都不是。
I'd much rather be thought of as Lauren. It's a lot sexier.
我宁愿被认为是劳伦。那性感多了。
Well, you know, we didn't actually think of you as a sex object when we were thinking of Miss Ames. We thought of you as an angel coming out of the sky.
嗯，你知道，当我们想到艾姆斯小姐时，其实并没把你当成性对象。我们把你当成从天而降的天使。
Well, that's good too.
嗯，那也很好。
Here's how they found her. Gabriela finally got her hands on that list of all the teachers certified in the state of Georgia. She noticed one of the women named Ames had allowed her certification to lapse. This one Ames, she tracked down in West Virginia and left messages for her saying only that she was looking for an English teacher on behalf of a former student.
他们找到她的方式如下。加布里埃拉终于拿到了佐治亚州所有获得认证的教师名单。她注意到有一位姓Ames的女性让她的证书过期了。这个Ames，她追踪到了西弗吉尼亚州，并给她留了信息，只说她代表一名以前的学生寻找一名英语老师。
And I immediately knew. She didn't mention Emir's name. I just knew. It never crossed my mind that it would be anybody but Emir, frankly. I mean, I knew one day he'd be a famous something.
我立刻就知道了。她没提埃米尔的名字。我就是知道。说实话，我从来没想过会是别人，只能是埃米尔。我的意思是，我知道有一天他会成名。
The basic plan was to fly Miss Ames to Chicago to meet Emir, but I wanted to ask her what she remembered before Emir had a chance to tell her what she should remember. She told me that she was 36 years old when she arrived at Clarkston High as a student teacher. She'd recently married a man named Chris Ames, and they decided they wouldn't have children of their own. She thinks that maybe the faint regrets of that decision made her want to go out of her way to help some kid.
基本的计划是把艾姆斯小姐飞到芝加哥去见埃米尔，但在埃米尔有机会告诉她她应该记得什么之前，我想问问她记得什么。她告诉我，她来到克拉克斯顿高中当实习老师时是36岁。她刚嫁给了一个叫克里斯·艾姆斯（Chris Ames）的男人，他们决定不生自己的孩子。她认为，可能这个决定带来的隐约遗憾让她想要竭尽全力去帮助某个孩子。
Anyway, she noticed this extremely talented boy in her class and watched him, not for two weeks as an intern, as Emir had told me, but for many months, an entire semester in which she was put in charge of his class, she says, as his full-time English teacher. And how was Emir's English at the time?
总之，她注意到了班上这个非常有才华的男孩，并观察他，不是像埃米尔告诉我的那样作为实习生待了两周，而是好几个月，整个学期她都被指派负责他的班级，她说，作为他的全职英语老师。当时埃米尔的英语怎么样？
It was tremendous. It was absolutely tremendous, really, really good.
太棒了。真的非常、非常棒。
There were other differences in their stories. For example, Emir said the public school was terrifying and useless. Miss Ames didn't agree.
他们的故事里还有其他分歧。例如，埃米尔说公立学校很恐怖且毫无用处。艾姆斯小姐不同意。
Well certainly, there were drugs. And I'm sure there was some violence, but it wasn't a ghetto school. No, it was a quirky, quasi-city, quasi-suburban school that had a great student body that was interesting because they were from so many different places.
嗯，当然有毒品。我肯定也有暴力事件，但那不是贫民窟学校。不，那是一所古怪的、准城市、准郊区的学校，有着很棒的学生群体，很有趣，因为他们来自这么多不同的地方。
By that, she means from all over the world-- Kenya, Somalia, Bosnia, Vietnam, Korea. The place was like a teenage UN, in her telling. But the most glaring gap between their two stories was a central plot point, the key moment, the plagiarized essay. In Emir's version, it's what saves him. But Miss Ames doesn't even remember it. She recalls the moment she decided to move him to private school this way.
她的意思是来自全世界——肯尼亚、索马里、波斯尼亚、越南、韩国。用她的话说，那个地方就像是青少年版的联合国。但他们两个故事之间最明显的鸿沟是一个中心情节，那个关键时刻，剽窃的文章。在埃米尔的版本里，它是救命稻草。但艾姆斯小姐甚至不记得了。她这样回忆她决定送他去私立学校的那一刻。
Well, actually, I think it was the day that he diagrammed sentences for me on the blackboard for the rest of the students. [LAUGHS] I couldn't, for the life of me, figure out how to make them learn it. And it was just mind-numbingly boring.
嗯，事实上，我想是那天他在黑板上为其他学生分析句子结构的时候。[笑声] 我无论如何也想不出怎么让他们学会。那简直无聊透了。
And Emir said to me, you know, I really think I can explain this, and they'll understand it. So he took over. And it was a great class, and he did a wonderful job. And it just occurred to me, right there on the spot, this kid is just capable of so much more than this school can offer him.
然后埃米尔对我说，你知道，我真的觉得我能解释清楚，他们会明白的。于是他接手了。那是一堂很棒的课，他做得非常出色。就在那一刻，我脑子里闪过一个念头，这个孩子的能力远超这所学校能提供给他的。
Still, no essay. I give her a little nudge.
依然没有文章。我推了她一下。
And do you remember any particular piece of work he did? When you think back of his work as a student, did anything in particular catch your attention?
你还记得他做的任何特定作业吗？当你回想他作为学生的作业时，有什么特别引起你注意的吗？
He wrote an essay about losing his dad in Bosnia and his family coming to America. That was incredibly moving and beautifully written.
他写过一篇关于在波斯尼亚失去父亲、全家来到美国的文章。那篇极其感人，写得非常漂亮。
Huh. It sounds like a different essay, but at least it's an essay. But as soon as she brings up the essay, she drops it.
哈。听起来像是另一篇文书，但至少那是篇文书。但当她提到文书时，她就没再深究了。
We took a stab, I remember, at poetry in that class, and he was very good at that. He understood meter right away. But I did speak with his math and science teachers, and they said that he was working at a level that was beyond anything that was taught, even in the senior year at the AP level, and that they just were trying to find things to give him to do because he was just so advanced.
我记得我们当时试着写过诗，他在那方面很棒。他立刻就懂了格律。但我跟他的数学和科学老师谈过，他们说他的水平超出了当时所教的内容，甚至超出了AP高级水平，他们只是在试图找事情给他做，因为他太先进了。
The essay on which Emir has based his entire life story had nothing to do with her decision to help him. That much was clear. It was also clear that Miss Ames hadn't grabbed him on some mistaken whim, but only after observing his rare combination of genius and kindness for months. And then she'd gone and created a battle plan to move him out of public school and into private. She didn't ever have any job interview at the private school. She thinks maybe she told him that just to avoid getting his hopes up.
埃米尔基于此作为人生故事基础的那篇文书，与她帮助他的决定毫无关系。那点很清楚。同样清楚的是，艾姆斯小姐并不是因为一时兴起才帮他，而是在观察了他好几个月的天才和善良结合之后。然后她制定了战斗计划，把他从公立学校转到了私立学校。她从来没有在私立学校进行过任何工作面试。她认为可能她那么说只是为了避免他失望。
I had done a lot of investigation. I met with my colleagues over there, and sent records over, and made a lot of sales pitches, and was told that there may not be enough scholarship money. It was kind of late, this and that, but I kept pushing and pushing. And finally, we got him an appointment over there.
我做了很多调查。我跟那里的同事会面，寄送记录，并做了很多销售陈述，被告知奖学金可能不够。当时已经有点晚了，诸如此类，但我一直不断地推动。最终，我们让他获得了那里的面试机会。
It isn't just the details that conflict here, it's the whole moral of the story. Miss Ames doesn't believe for a minute that she made all that much of a difference to Emir. She thinks he was so ridiculously gifted that he would've gone on to greater things, even if he'd stayed at Clarkston.
这里冲突的不仅仅是细节，而是整个故事的寓意。艾姆斯小姐一点也不相信她对埃米尔有多大影响。她认为他天赋太高了，即使留在克拉克斯顿，他也会走向伟大的事业。
Well, you know, frankly, he didn't even need to go to high school. He could have gone straight to college. He just needed to grow up. I mean, I'm not joking. I just don't think any teacher would get another student like Emir in a lifetime. I had my once-in-a-lifetime student right off the bat.
嗯，你知道，坦白说，他甚至不需要上高中。他本可以直接读大学。他只是需要长大。我的意思是，我没开玩笑。我只是认为任何老师一生中都不会再遇到像埃米尔这样的学生。我一上来就遇到了我一生中唯一的那个学生。
Did you feel any impulse to get back in touch with him?
你有冲动想跟他重新取得联系吗？
No, let the chicks fly. I'm not really a kid person. Sorry. [LAUGHS] No. You know, we had our own lives, and I wanted him to have his life. And I didn't earn his way into Paideia or Harvard, he did it. It's his accomplishment.
没有，让小鸟飞吧。我不是那种喜欢孩子的人。抱歉。[笑声] 没有。你知道，我们有自己的生活，我想让他有他自己的生活。我没帮他争取进入派地亚或哈佛，是他自己做到的。那是他的成就。
What happens when the story a person is telling about his life gets fact checked? I don't mean what happens when you say you graduated from college when you actually didn't. And your employer finds out, and you get fired. I mean, what happens when you really want to believe your life story was this. And then you get told by someone who knows better, nope, actually it wasn't this, it was that?
当一个人讲述的人生故事被核实后会发生什么？我指的不是你谎称从大学毕业其实没毕业，然后雇主发现了被开除。我指的是，当你真的想相信你的人生故事是这样，然后被一个更清楚的人告诉你，不，其实不是这样，而是那样，会发生什么？
You swear you haven't called him?
你发誓你没给他打过电话？
No, I wouldn't do-- I'm honest.
没，我不会那样做——我很诚实。
I know you're honest.
我知道你很诚实。
A few weeks later, Miss Ames and I meet up in Chicago. We're visiting Emir at his job at the University of Chicago Business School. Up until the time she got our call, the only way Miss Ames has even tried to keep track of Emir is by checking the list of Nobel Prize winners each year to see if his name is on it. And oddly enough, it's not a totally crazy way to try to keep track of him. He hasn't gotten the Nobel Prize yet, but he's the sort of person who might. His colleagues say he's brilliant, and half of them already have gotten the Nobel Prize.
几周后，艾姆斯小姐和我在芝加哥见面。我们去拜访在芝加哥大学商学院工作的埃米尔。直到她接到我们的电话，艾姆斯小姐跟踪埃米尔的唯一方式是每年查阅诺贝尔奖获奖者名单，看有没有他的名字。奇怪的是，这不是追踪他的疯狂方法。他还没拿诺贝尔奖，但他可能是那种可能会拿到的人。他的同事说他很出色，他们中有一半已经拿了诺贝尔奖。
Excuse me, where can we get an elevator to the fifth floor?
打扰一下，在哪能坐电梯去五楼？
The Chicago Business School feels less like a school than the headquarters of a highly successful corporation or maybe a Swiss resort.
芝加哥商学院感觉与其说是学校，不如说是某家极其成功的企业或瑞士度假村的总部。
This way. There he is.
这边走。他就在那。
Hi.
嗨。
Hello--
你好——
Hi.
嗨。
--gorgeous.
——美极了。
OK. And at that point, we have to take a break. What happens when Emir and Miss Ames sit down and compare notes about his past? Michael Lewis will be back with that in just one minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
好的。到那时我们得休息一下。当埃米尔和艾姆斯小姐坐下来比较彼此对他的记忆时会发生什么？迈克尔·刘易斯将在仅仅一分钟后带着答案回来，在我们的节目继续时，从芝加哥公共广播电台播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "How I Got Into College." We first aired this show a few years back.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“我是如何考上大学的”。我们几年前第一次播出了这个节目。
Michael Lewis, if you heard before the break, he's telling the story of two people who are seeing each other again for the very first time in two decades. And let's just pick up right where we left off before the break.
迈克尔·刘易斯，如果你在休息前听到的话，他正在讲述两个人二十年来第一次见面。让我们接着休息前停下的地方继续。
Hi.
嗨。
Hello--
你好——
Hi.
嗨。
--gorgeous. It's wonderful to see you after all this time.
——美极了。这么久以后见到你真是太棒了。
Indeed. Indeed.
确实。确实。
Thanks, for having us.
谢谢你们来。
Well, thank you for coming in.
嗯，谢谢你们过来。
Emir and Miss Ames make awkward chit chat for a few minutes, and then we all go into his office to talk. There's a giant, vaguely familiar painting on one of the walls. Emir explains that it's a forgery by some guy in China who specializes in them. Miss Ames is more interested in his coffee table.
埃米尔和艾姆斯小姐尴尬地闲聊了几分钟，然后我们都进他的办公室谈话。墙上有一幅巨大的、隐约眼熟的画。埃米尔解释说那是中国某位专门做这个的家伙伪造的。艾姆斯小姐对他咖啡桌更感兴趣。
Do you know my parents had that exact same coffee table in our house growing up?
你知道我父母在家里长大的时候就有那张一模一样的咖啡桌吗？
But this is a knockoff.
但这是个仿制品。
That's a knockoff.
那是个仿制品。
Yeah, it's a knockoff.
是的，是个仿制品。
It's a knockoff, but it is beautiful.
这是仿制品，但它很漂亮。
It's a plagiarized piece of furniture?
这是一件剽窃的家具？
Well, it's a very poorly done knockoff Noguchi.
嗯，这是一个做得非常糟糕的仿制品野口勇设计。
Yes.
是的。
You can tell it's not real, so I don't think it counts as plagiarism.
看得出它不是真的，所以我认为它不算剽窃。
[INAUDIBLE] he had real Noguchi.
[听不清] 他有真正的野口勇。
Anything else around here that's not what it purports to be?
这里还有什么东西不是它看起来的样子？
That's a fake skull of a giant rodent.
那是一个巨型啮齿动物的假头骨。
We eventually settle into Emir's office and turn our attention to Emir's memories, which, thanks to Miss Ames, are suddenly a little problematic themselves. He tells his story all over again until he gets to what he sees as its biggest turning point.
我们最终在埃米尔的办公室里安定下来，将注意力转向埃米尔的记忆，由于艾姆斯小姐的存在，这些记忆本身突然变得有点问题了。他把他的故事重讲了一遍，直到他讲到他认为是最大转折点的地方。
So I try to put down, to the extent which I could, word for word, this beautiful passage from this accomplished writer.
所以我尽量尝试，在我能做的范围内，逐字逐句地写下这位出色作家的美丽段落。
He doesn't change any of the facts, but his tone is just a tiny bit less certain, maybe because he sees Miss Ames writhing in her chair.
他没改变任何事实，但他的语调稍微有一点不确定，也许是因为他看到艾姆斯小姐在椅子上扭动。
Yeah. I mouthed to you, he plagiarized it. I'm horrified.
是的。我跟你做了个口型，他剽窃了。我被吓到了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm truly horrified. No one wants to be duped.
我真的被吓到了。没人想被愚弄。
Here's the safest way to plagiarize-- do it in the distant past. The teacher is no longer capable of getting angry about it, and the plagiarist is no longer even faintly embarrassed. Emir finishes his story with the same punchline, in that brief moment, Miss Ames mistakes him for a genius and gets him into a school that gets him into Harvard. But Miss Ames is now shaking her head.
这里有个剽窃的最安全方法——在遥远的过去做。老师没能力为此生气，而剽窃者甚至不会感到丝毫尴尬。埃米尔以同样的笑料结束了他的故事，在那个短暂的瞬间，艾姆斯小姐误以为他是天才，并将他送进了一所能让他进入哈佛的学校。但艾姆斯小姐现在摇着头。
It didn't happen that fast, though. It was April when we went. You know, I'd already worked with you for a couple of months when we went in to see--
不过没那么快发生。我们去的时候是四月。你知道，在我们去见派地亚的人之前，我已经和你一起工作了几个月了——
Do you remember that?
你记得吗？
--to see the people at Paideia. I'd seen a lot more work than just one essay. And seeing what he could do in class on a daily basis was more impressive to me.
去见派地亚的人。我看到的不仅是一篇文书。观察他每天在课堂上的表现对我来说印象更深刻。
It's about now that Emir begins to see that Miss Ames is screwing up his life story. The plagiarized essay is the key to the thing. Without it, his story and his life isn't about luck and chance and the guiding hand of a guardian angel he didn't deserve, it's about something else. And he doesn't want it to be about something else.
差不多就在这个时候，埃米尔开始发现艾姆斯小姐正在搞砸他的人生故事。剽窃的文章是事情的关键。如果没有它，他的故事和人生就不是关于运气、偶然和一位他不配得到的守护天使的引导，而是关于其他东西。但他不想它是关于其他东西。
I recognize that my memory of it is somewhat spotty, but I do have what seems like a pretty distinct memory of the essay sort of triggering the conversation that, you should get out of this school, followed very closely on the heels--
我意识到我对它的记忆有点模糊，但我确实有相当清晰的记忆，文章触发了对话，你应该离开这所学校，非常紧接着——
It may have, but I was already convinced.
也许是吧，但我当时已经确信了。
--of the essay.
——那篇文章之后。
I promise you.
我向你保证。
So it still could have been the proximate cause, even if not the deep cause.
所以它可能仍然是直接原因，即使不是深层原因。
OK.
好的。
But not really. There's a bunch of stuff, she says, which he can't bring himself to accept. For instance, that the school she pulled him out of wasn't an educational dead end, but an interesting and diverse place in which he could have gotten a great education.
并不完全是。她有好多事说，他无法接受。例如，她带他离开的那所学校不是教育死胡同，而是一个有趣且多元化的地方，他本可以在那里获得良好的教育。
I remember the racial mix as being very few-- I remember being one of 12 white kids in a school of 900. That's not right?
我记得种族比例很少——我记得在900人的学校里我是12个白人孩子之一。那不对吗？
I think it was probably more 40% African American, 40% international and kids from all over the world. And about 20% of the kids were white kids who were longtime Clarkston residents. Family after family lived there.
我想大概是40%非裔美国人，40%来自世界各地的国际生。大约20%的孩子是长期居住在克拉克斯顿的白人孩子。一家接一家都住在那儿。
That's certainly not my recollection. But then again, this is a matter for research rather than debate. It's probably easy to check.
那肯定不是我的记忆。但话又说回来，这是一个研究而非辩论的问题。这可能很容易核实。
Here it is, a single objective fact that they disagree about that can be checked, a fact that might shed light on whose version of this story is more strictly true. So later, we checked it. The school district couldn't give us statistics for the year Emir was there, but they have them for the following year.
事实就在这里，一个他们意见不一的单一客观事实可以被核实，一个可能揭示谁的版本更严格真实的真理事实。所以后来，我们核实了。学区无法提供埃米尔在那里的那一年的数据，但他们有下一年的。
Emir's estimate that he was one of a dozen white kids in the school leaves out, oh, roughly 200 other white kids. They made up 17% of the school, pretty close to Miss Ames' estimate. Emir listens politely to Miss Ames' account of how and why she helped him and how and why it didn't actually matter all that much, as he was clearly destined for great things.
埃米尔估计他是学校里12个白人孩子之一，漏掉了大概200个其他白人孩子。他们占了学校的17%，非常接近艾姆斯小姐的估计。埃米尔礼貌地听取了艾姆斯小姐关于她如何以及为什么帮他，以及如何以及为什么这其实并没有多大关系，因为他显然注定会有伟大的事业。
You would have gotten into the honors program at UGA from Clarkston or gone to Georgia Tech. And from an undergraduate degree in the honors program at UGA or Georgia Tech, you could have gotten into Harvard for a PhD, or Chicago, or Stanford. I mean, it's doable. It happens. I know people who've done it.
你本来会从克拉克斯顿进入佐治亚大学荣誉项目或者进入佐治亚理工。而从佐治亚大学或佐治亚理工的荣誉项目本科毕业后，你本来可以进入哈佛攻读博士，或者芝加哥，或者斯坦福。我的意思是，这完全做得到。这会发生的。我知道有人做到了。
If Emir cares what Miss Ames thinks, he's doing a pretty good job of hiding his interest. It isn't until she describes what happened after she helped him out that he becomes truly excited.
如果埃米尔在乎艾姆斯小姐怎么想，他隐藏自己的兴趣隐藏得很好。直到她描述在她帮他之后发生了什么，他才真正兴奋起来。
There were quite a few people at the school who weren't thrilled with the fact that I poached their best student, so they sent me to the absolute worst school in the county and put me under the new principal there, who had been the assistant principal at Clarkston. And he brought me in his office and said, you know, you've got a lot of high-minded ideas, and you don't know what you're talking about, and it's going to be my job to break you in, and you're going to learn how to do this right, and so forth and so on.
学校里有相当多的人对她挖走他们最好的学生不高兴，所以他们把我送到了该郡最差的学校，并把我置于那里的新校长之下，他曾是克拉克斯顿的副校长。他把我带到他的办公室说，你知道，你有很多自以为是的想法，你根本不知道你在说什么，而把你驯服将是我的工作，你会学会如何正确地做这件事，诸如此类。
And it was really rough year. He did break me in. In fact, he broke me because I quit. I couldn't take it anymore.
那真是艰难的一年。他的确驯服了我。事实上，他打垮了我，因为我辞职了。我再也受不了了。
So he did this because you had poached Emir from the school?
所以他这样做是因为你从学校挖走了埃米尔？
To be totally honest with you, yeah.
跟你说实话，是的。
For helping Emir to move from the public school to the private school, Miss Ames was more or less driven out of teaching. She quit, changed careers, and eventually moved with her husband to West Virginia, where she's now an interior designer.
因为帮助埃米尔从公立学校转到私立学校，艾姆斯小姐或多或少被赶出了教学界。她辞职了，换了职业，最终和丈夫搬到了西弗吉尼亚州，现在是室内设计师。
I mean, wait. So to get this right, you are telling me not only did you go through all of this trouble, but--
我的意思是，等等。所以为了弄清楚这一点，你是告诉我，你不仅经历了所有这些麻烦，而且——
I told you, this wasn't fair.
我告诉过你，这不公平。
Why is it not fair? It's incredibly important. It transforms what-- you know, this is just changing by the minute from my conceptualization of, you know, well, you know, we-- for two weeks, you said, you should go to this place.
为什么不公平？这非常重要。它改变了什么——你知道，这对我从我对你……（你说）两周时间，你应该去那个地方的概念化（产生改变）。
It was fantastic. It made all the difference. That's enough, because that changed my life. So what I'm learning only now is that you did all of these things, and then that you were basically cast out of the apparent paradise, which is Clarkston, which I still find a little doubling, increasing by an order of magnitude what was already an enormous amount of gratitude.
那太棒了。那起了所有的作用。这就够了，因为那改变了我的人生。所以我现在才了解到你做了所有这些事，然后你基本上被逐出了克拉克斯顿那个看似的天堂，这依然让我觉得有点加倍，将原本巨大的感激之情提高了一个数量级。
That night, Emir invited Miss Ames to his house for dinner and to meet his wife and 18-month-old daughter. He wanted to show her the life that he never would have had if not for her.
那天晚上，埃米尔邀请艾姆斯小姐去他家吃晚饭，认识他的妻子和18个月大的女儿。他想向她展示如果没有她，他永远不会拥有的生活。
[BABY CRYING]
[婴儿哭声]
Hi, sweetheart.
嗨，亲爱的。
Much, much later, after dinner and drinks, and more drinks, and after he's passed out some stiff cocktail from the old country, I ask Emir how it'll change his life story, now that he's heard what actually happened. He said he'd incorporate the fact that Miss Ames got punished for helping him, which of course only makes the story better. She's now not only an angel, but a martyr. But what about the plagiarized essay from the stolen library book on which the whole story turns?
很多、很多年后，晚饭和喝酒过后，再喝了几杯，在他奉上一些来自老家的高度烈酒后，我问埃米尔，现在他听到了实际发生了什么，他的人生故事会怎样改变。他说他会把艾姆斯小姐因为帮他而受到惩罚这个事实加入进去，这当然只会让故事更好。她现在不仅是天使，还是殉道者。但那个从偷来的图书馆书里剽窃的文章呢，故事的整个转折点就在它上面。
I mean, suppose that the story was-- just let's kind of do a thought experiment-- there was no recollection of the essay, none whatsoever. I wouldn't enjoy telling the story about the essay at that point.
我的意思是，假设故事是——让我们做一个思想实验——对那篇文章根本没有记忆，完全没有。到那时候，我就不会喜欢讲关于那篇文章的故事了。
Wait. We don't have to do that thought experiment. That's what really happened. Miss Ames actually didn't remember the essay. Emir's already forgotten that fact.
等等。我们不需要做那个思想实验。那才是真正发生的事。艾姆斯小姐其实根本不记得那篇文章。埃米尔已经忘记了那个事实。
I wasn't convinced by the alternative account. Genuinely, because it was so apparent that I was also diagramming sentences, which does make a far worse story, dramatically speaking. I diagrammed this sentence. And boy, you know how well I diagrammed it? It was just fantastic. I mean, the verbs, and the nouns, and the adjectives, and the adverbs were all just separate.
我对另一个解释不信服。真的，因为我很显然当时也在分析句子结构，戏剧性地讲，那使故事变得更糟。我分析了这个句子。天哪，你知道我分析得有多好吗？简直太棒了。我的意思是，动词、名词、形容词和副词全部分开了。
I didn't really see the point of torturing Emir any further. He needed his story to be what it was, and so he was sticking to it. The question was, why? What did it do for him? Why does a man who makes his career as a scientist cling to his story, in spite of evidence that it isn't true? And that's when it dawns on me, Emir Kamenica is just an unusually happy human being. He exudes the emotion from every pore.
我没必要再继续折磨埃米尔了。他需要他的故事是那个样子，所以他坚持下去了。问题是，为什么？它为他做了什么？为什么一个以科学为职业的人，尽管有证据表明不是真的，却紧紧抓住他的故事不放？就在那时我意识到，埃米尔·卡门尼卡只是一个不同寻常的快乐的人。他身上每一个毛孔都洋溢着这种情绪。
Have you always been happy?
你一直都这么快乐吗？
I think I've been happy for a pretty long time now.
我想我已经快乐很长一段时间了。
Now, there's no obvious connection between a person's happiness and the way he tells stories about himself, but I think there's a not so obvious one. When you insist the way that Emir does that you're both lucky and indebted to other people, well, you're sort of prepared to see life as a happy accident, aren't you? It's just very different than if you tell yourself that you simply deserve all the good stuff that happens to you because you happen to be born a genius, or suffered so much, or worked so hard. That way of telling the story-- well, that's what you hear from every miserable bond trader at Goldman Sachs, or for that matter, every other A-hole who ever walked the earth.
现在，一个人快乐与否和他讲关于自己的故事方式之间没有明显的联系，但我认为有一种不那么明显的联系。当你像埃米尔那样坚持认为你既幸运又欠别人的情时，嗯，你某种程度上准备好了把生活视为一场快乐的意外，不是吗？这和你告诉自己，仅仅因为你生来是个天才，或者受了这么多苦，或者工作如此努力，你就理应得到发生在自己身上的一切好事，是完全不同的。讲故事的那种方式——嗯，那是你从高盛每一个悲惨的债券交易员身上，或者说，每一个曾经走在地球上的混蛋身上听到的话。
It's at this exact moment when the subject of happiness comes up that Emir's wife, Yelena, becomes very interested.
就在这个提到快乐主题的瞬间，埃米尔的妻子耶莱娜（Yelena）变得非常感兴趣。
Both I know it and all of my friends know that he's the happiest person that we've met. You can't fake it. You can't decide that I'm just going to be happy, because it will unravel very quickly. And you will find reasons to be grumpy.
我知道它，我的所有朋友也都知道他是我们见过最快乐的人。你装不出来的。你无法决定说我要快乐，因为那会很快瓦解。而且你会找到理由变得暴躁。
The reason her husband's so happy, she thinks, has to do with the way he filters the world around him, the way he decides not just what to think about, but how to think about it. She says she sees him do this all the time.
她认为她丈夫之所以这么快乐，与他过滤周围世界的方式有关，与他决定不只是想什么、而是如何思考有关。她说她经常看他这样做。
It's a micro decision. I've seen him get some news and decide how to feel about that. It's a practiced decision, but I still observed Emir making that decision. And I've tried to crack that code by living with him. [CHUCKLES]
这是一个微小的决定。我见过他得到一些新闻并决定对此感到什么样。这是一个练习过的决定，但我观察到埃米尔在做那个决定。我一直尝试通过和他生活在一起来破解那个密码。[笑声]
Crack what code?
破解什么密码？
The code of happiness, making that decision of how you're going to feel about something.
快乐的密码，决定你对某件事感觉如何。
These stories we tell about ourselves, they're almost like our infrastructure, like railroads or highways. We can build them almost any way we want to. But once they're in place, this whole inner landscape grows up around them.
这些我们讲述关于自己的故事，几乎就像我们的基础设施，像铁路或高速公路。我们几乎可以以任何我们想要的方式构建它们。但一旦它们到位，整个内心风景就会围绕着它们成长。
So maybe the point here is that you should be careful about how you tell your story, or at least conscious of it. Because once you've told it, once you've built the highway, it's just very hard to move it. Even if your story is about an angel who came out of nowhere and saved your life, even then, not even the angel herself can change it.
所以也许这里的重点是你应该小心你讲述故事的方式，或者至少意识到它。因为一旦你讲了它，一旦你建好了高速公路，就很难搬走它。即使你的故事是关于一个从天而降救了你命的天使，即便如此，连天使自己也无法改变它。
Michael Lewis. His newest book is called The Coming Storm. It is only available as an audio book. Is this the future, friends? It's available exclusively on audible.com. Emir and his wife, Yelena, now have two little kids. They're still in Chicago.
迈克尔·刘易斯。他的最新书叫《即将来临的风暴》（The Coming Storm）。它仅以有声读物形式提供。这是未来吗，朋友们？它独家在audible.com上提供。埃米尔和他的妻子耶莱娜现在有两个小孩。他们还在芝加哥。
[MUSIC - THE QUEERS, "I WANNA BE HAPPY"]
[音乐 - THE QUEERS, "I WANNA BE HAPPY"]
(SINGING) I wanna be happy. I don't wanna be sad. I wanna be a good boy. I don't wanna be bad. I wanna be happy, yeah, I wanna be happy so bad. I wanna be happy, yeah, I really do, but everybody's saying I'm no good for you. They know I'm a cretin and I know it's true, but I don't care.
（演唱）我想快乐。我不想悲伤。我想当个好男孩。我不想变坏。我想快乐，耶，我太想快乐了。我想快乐，耶，我真心想，但每个人都说我配不上你。他们知道我是个白痴，我也知道那是真的，但我不在乎。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Production help from Anna Martin. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Mixing help today from Catherine Raimondo. Research help from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damian Graef from Rob Geddis.
我们今天的节目由南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）和我制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）一起。我们今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作协助来自安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。今天的混音协助来自凯瑟琳·雷蒙多（Catherine Raimondo）。研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graef）和罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。
Special thanks today to Sarah Craig, Jim Richards, Claire Vaye Watkins, Joe Jennings, Rachel [? Colwell, ?] and Serving by Irving. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can hear any of our old episodes for absolutely free, or download as many as you like using the This American Life app. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
特别感谢今天莎拉·克雷格（Sarah Craig）、吉姆·理查兹（Jim Richards）、克莱尔·维伊·沃特金斯（Claire Vaye Watkins）、乔·詹宁斯（Joe Jennings）、瑞秋·科尔韦尔（Rachel Colwell）和“欧文服务”。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们任何旧节目，或者使用“This American Life”应用程序下载任意多的集数。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心发行。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. I beat him at backgammon last night. I don't know. He took it hard.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。我昨晚在双陆棋上赢了他。我不知道。他很难受。
I'm slowly becoming a repository for decomposing sorrows, regrets, ignored injustice, forgotten promises.
我正在慢慢成为分解的悲伤、遗憾、被忽视的不公、被遗忘的承诺的储存库。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
[MUSIC - THE QUEERS, "I WANNA BE HAPPY"]
[音乐 - THE QUEERS, "I WANNA BE HAPPY"]
(SINGING) It's all I wanna do. I wanna be happy with you. It's all I wanna do. I wanna be happy with you. It's all I wanna do. I wanna be happy with you. It's all I wanna do. I wanna be happy with you.
（演唱）那是我唯一想做的。我想和你一起快乐。那是我唯一想做的。我想和你一起快乐。那是我唯一想做的。我想和你一起快乐。那是我唯一想做的。我想和你一起快乐。